hello you're playing the waiting game
the last one 2013 in fact and with the
new year just around the corner or
already upon us depending on when you're
watching this we thought it'd be nice to
have a look at our five most anticipated
games of 2014 so in no particular order
well of course titan falls in the mix
we've already done a whole episode on
this game it's still worth talking about
mind because well we really want to play
it titanfall if you missed it isn't
online shooter pitting you against both
rival players and AI popcorn enemies
designed to let you farm experience
without a real person having to suffer
the frustration of dying every time you
make a kill those are the core gameplay
mechanics but it's the physical mechs
that really count because if you do well
enough you get to pilot one of the
game's eponymous Titans exploring the
game world is also refreshingly
different with double jump and mantling
abilities adding an element of
verticality few shooters attempt unless
we're talking about brink and I'm pretty
sure we're not whether or not you really
care about double jumps and big machines
it'll certainly be interesting to see
how respawn entertainment fair with
their first game
next is tom clancy's the division or as
you may remember it from the e3
announcement tom clancy's that game
where the dude closes the door as he
moves along side the car for cover what
can I say I'm a sucker for the small
details the plot of tom clancy's that
game where the dude closes the door as
he moves along side the car for cover is
as follows on Black Friday a disease
begins to ravage the United States in
just five days the whole country
collapses you play as a member of a
group called the strategic homeland
division or the division for short
striving to salvage as much of the
nation as it can from the ashes shooting
AI targets and real-world players in the
process finally way to go about
rebuilding a country if you ask me but
then no one's ever asked me to try while
the division was initially going to be a
next-gen console exclusive enough fans
raised a clamor to get the pc version
signed off by ubisoft thereby raising
the number of people who'll be able to
play it when it launches in 2014 so
that'll be nice next on the list is the
long-awaited Metal Gear Solid 5 the
phantom pain okay let's try and ignore
that thing a few months ago when Kajima
started jabbering on about how erotic he
wanted to make the game as the stealth
action title still looks pretty decent
snake has borrowed kiefer sutherland's
voice and face for an all-new adventure
in which he wakes up after nine years in
a coma taking the new name punished
snakey then ventures into Afghanistan
during the Soviet war to find those
responsible with a totally open world
and some sweet stealth horse action mgs5
seems to be quite an ambitious offering
for the series which after 25 years of
franchise history will either make fans
very happy or very angry we can't wait
to see which all right we're nearly
there with our most anticipated games of
2014 and the next is another we've
already covered on this show what are
the odds quite high actually I wasn't
always this guy
yes technically it's supposed to be out
by now but then that pesky delay came in
and ruined everything nonetheless
watchdogs looks very interesting indeed
putting you in charge of super hacker
Aiden feel free to roam the open world
merrily hacking your way into all sorts
of things bank accounts phones even
traffic lights if causing car crashes is
your thing with gameplay demo so far
showing aid in helping a fellow hacker
escape and even going on a cheeky
assassination run it looks like they'll
be plenty to do in the games version of
Chicago interestingly you can even
infiltrate another player's campaign
mode without them knowing and try and
hack into that person's data without
them noticing and killing you just
perfect if your new year's resolution is
to grief more people over the Internet
and finally in this New Year's special
is the game set to be the most amusing
unpredictable and possibly offensive
release of 2014 I don't even really need
to say it do I there it is the end of
the giggling down yes south park the
stick of truth is the role playing game
we least expected to see under
development by obsidian entertainment
the folks who handled Fallout New Vegas
the stick of truth makes you the new kid
in the sweary cartoon Colorado town with
the sense of humor every bit as
outlandish as the show it's based on you
might be forgiven for thinking the
gameplay maybe a little light especially
given some of the South Park games that
are preceded it because frankly they
sucked astoundingly though the gameplay
looks as deep as any RPG you'd care to
mention with turn-based combat potions
abilities and weapon add-ons all adding
complexity without skipping on the fun
as demonstrated by the ability to kick
ones foes in the nuts
and with that I think it's about time to
kick 2013 in the nuts a very happy new
year to each and every one of you I'll
be back next week when the show will be
back to its usual book film game and TV
peddling self if you have any
recommendations to make in the meantime
please do leave us a comment or tweet
with the hashtag GS waiting game happy
new year